good evening i'm jason chaffetz in for
laura ingraham and welcome to this
ingram angle special the left and
lawlessness we've got an incredible show
for you tonight with example after
example of liberals ignoring the law
when it served their political interests
the GOP has always been the party of law
and order but we're in uncharted
territory when it comes to the left
whether it's sanctuary cities
decriminalizing drugs or failing to stop
rampant crime in places like San
Francisco or Chicago the left routinely
puts ideology over the need to enforce
the laws on the books and we start
tonight with more examples of Americans
victimized by crimes by illegal
immigrants the latest on Fox news.com
right now an Illinois judge slamming
officials for failing to enforce a 2012
ice detainer against illegal immigrant
Miguel Luna who was later able to beat
and rape three women mr. Luna was
sentenced to 80 years in prison on
Monday let me tell you about two more
stories sad stories tragic stories
hailey King was just 18 years old when
in November of 2016
she was fatally hit by a speeding truck
the driver an illegal immigrant named
Sergio Rodriguez he didn't stop after
the accident because he feared being
deported and it doesn't get more tragic
than this Dimitri Smith lived for just
one minute
outside her mother's womb he was
delivered in an emergency c-section
after an illegal immigrant crashed into
his mother's car in New Mexico in 2012
Haley's mother Kathy Hall as well as
Dimitri's mother Aileen Smith both join
me to share their stories they're
sitting side by side there Aileen Kathy
I appreciate you coming on the show and
I our heart goes out to everybody who
goes through this as a parent myself I
can't even imagine the sadness that that
has gone through your family and we
appreciate your your taking these
moments and being brave enough to come
share your stories in your perspective
because I think this country you have
more of a voice than anybody like myself
or somebody who hasn't been through this
so Kathy
again I'm so sorry we went through this
but Donald Trump has brought a lot of
attention to the status the illegal
immigrant status is that the right thing
to do are we are we are we doing the
right thing by talking about the status
of these people I believe so my daughter
would still be here today if the man
would have stopped if he would have been
here legally I think that if the
American public isn't aware of how many
cases are actually are and what's going
on it Donald Trump isn't going to be
able to get anywhere with it and and I
lean in your situation we talk sometimes
about the status illegal air legal
sometimes people will argue hey that's
not really not cogent part of the
discussion but what's your perspective
what are your thoughts well I think his
immigration status or his citizenship
status has a lot to say about policy
implications going forward and how we
handle these kinds of things you know if
there is a deportation of in the mix of
this or if we need ice detainers or not
that's really important so as far as
policy going forward we definitely need
to look at these cases and include their
immigration status
I mean first and foremost we want to
remember those kids whose lives were
taken far far too early but in the case
of locking down the border and the
immigration policies that move forward
Kathy what would you like to see happen
what is the right thing that the United
States of America should do you know we
had a situation with my daughter's case
I've kind of been on both areas of the
fence with this one the borders need to
be locked down when they come over here
illegally they do commit crimes to stay
here illegally you know I think that if
we don't do something about the the
issue there it's going to go well beyond
the families that you are having on the
show my granddaughter was removed given
to a family that was not us after
my grand after my daughter died we are
still fighting today to try to get my
granddaughter back home with her family
where she needs to be but you know so
I've had both both sides of this issue
my daughter should be here
ilene son should be here many many many
other mothers and fathers and it's going
to be a lot more if we don't stop what's
going on now Eileen one of the public
policy discussions people in Congress
are debating you hear Democrats say that
we should get rid of ice that
immigration customs enforcement should
just be abolished there's some that want
more open borders how do you react to
that um I think I should start by saying
that I'm not anti-immigrant you know my
grandfather came here to America in 1955
became a citizen in 1960 but those who
are coming in illegally and committing
further crimes need to be redressed and
I think this is something that we can
easily correct I don't think anybody in
their right mind would sit there and say
that we need to abolish ice they keep
our country safe god bless those men and
women yeah I agree
it's it's so true Cathy Eileen I want to
give you just a teach a moment but tell
us about your your loss and how you want
us to remember your you know how do you
want us to remember Haley for instance
and you know Haley was the youngest of
four children she was always happy
laughing loved everybody she was hard of
hearing and she could play music
beautifully but there wasn't anybody in
this world and Haley wouldn't have put
her hand out to help if they needed it
and I just you know if anything could
ever be considered good coming out of
this I'm hoping that her story will get
out there and help save some other lives
and Eileen what would what can you tell
us about Demetri and and what you were
going through at that time as a young
mother Demetri was my first child
he was incredible fully-formed
ten fingers ten toes had my nose had my
husband's hair and chin fit from elbow
to fingertip that's how big he was when
when I got to hold him before giving it
giving him off to Oh am i he was greatly
anticipated by my family it was one of
the first babies that we had had in
decades and he's sorely missed by his
family thank you for sharing your
stories I want to each give you one more
chance if you want to say something to
people who serve in Congress who are
public policymakers maybe let's start
with you Ilene first and then Cathy what
would you say to them well we are doing
the angel families rally on September in
DC so please join us for that a lot of
new angel moms are gonna be there people
who you know previously didn't get their
story out because they were wrapped up
in legal proceedings and things like
that so it would be very informative for
for sure in addition to that you know
wanting to see further legislation to
make sure that these people who are
committing heinous acts are deported
Cathy I agree with Eileen you know not
all the lawmakers out there are against
anything going on there are some very
good ones there are two state
representatives two state senators that
are helping with our case and then also
Senator Tom cotton has joined on board
and I'll be meeting with him in DC in
September also well again sorry for your
loss and I we appreciate you taking the
time and having the strength and
fortitude to be able to share your story
with others it's heart-wrenching and our
hearts go out to you but thank you again
for sharing your stories and being with
us tonight may God bless you well thank
you thank you for having us